what's that a cat toy Serena Williams
daughter Olympia confuses a tampon for a
cat toy what's that a cat toy for karma
it's a cat toy for our cat for karma
it's been amazing I've I never I've
always wanted to be a mom I love her so
much and you know we have a great little
family going on the tennis pro shared
this funny little family moment when her
five-year-old daughter thought the
feminine product was a toy for their cat
what's that a cat toy for karma it's a
cat toy for our cat for karma
[Music]
you got some more tattoos no because the
one with the feet
like let's see
from cat toys to the cat walk the mommy
daughter Duo seems to be spending a lot
of quality time together lately tell me
about your day we at the salon girl I
want to hear all about your day yeah the
athletes got hair styling skills and
advice on how to slay a Runway
work that Runway girl work that Runway
and cheering on loved ones runs deep in
this family
believe something about
last month at the U.S open Olympia was
Serena's biggest fan as the tennis icon
played what may have been her last
tournament Ever After announcing she's
evolving away from the sport I'm at an
age where I definitely have a lot more
to give and there's a lot more that I
want to do and so I'm not going to be
relaxing there's so much more for me and
yeah I feel it's more of like an
evolution of Serena Serena's little one
even twinned with Mama and paid homage
to her iconic braids it was either her
wear beads or me so I wanted to do it
but I just didn't have the time so um
yeah she she likes actually when she
asked to wear beads a lot
um but it actually wasn't my idea but I
was so happy when she had him on it's
perfect on her and Aunt Venus well she
couldn't help but gush over her scene
stealing niece what is it like for you
to have like a front row seat to that
beautiful bond between Serena and her
daughter I'm happy I get to be a part of
it and I thought you know we only could
do the fun stuff so
sign me up I have my priorities in
Olympia is that I'm never a day without
Olympia like she's my priority and every
day I like need to be home with her
because I don't I don't want to miss any
moments with her and it's moments like
this you know involving tampons that
double as cat toys we're sure Serena
never wants to miss what's that a cat
toy for karma it's a cat toy for our cat
for karma
foreign